DAVID EAST: You just finished
your app, and it looks great.
So let's call it a day, because
you're ready to rest, right?
Wrong.
I'm David East, and I'm
here to convince you
that you aren't done
yet, because you
need to build a widget.
But first, what
exactly is a widget?
Well, a widget just
consists of a single view
that is passed to other apps,
such as the Homescreen app.
And this view gets displayed
as a portion of their layout.
And that single view has now
become a window to your app
from the home screen,
or even the lock screen.
And this is where
the magic comes in,
because you can use that
widget to display information
that your users will
care about and to trigger
actions that will bring
them back into your app.
This means that you
have an opportunity
to become the core part of
your users' mobile experience.
And how cool is that?
Consider a simple,
non-interactive widget,
like for a weather app.
It can display the current
temperature overlaid
on a sunny sky to
show the weather
outside in a single
glance on the home screen.
Now you just gained
a grateful user,
because they don't actually
have to open up the app just
to check the weather.
But widgets are about doing
things, not just showing off.
So give that informative
view a job to do.
A click on the view
should trigger a deep link
into your app, but don't just
open up your main activity.
Instead consider, is there
a better point of entry,
such as the view for
this week's forecast?
Another use for a widget
could be a control toggle.
Perhaps you want to show how
strong the Wi-Fi signal is
right now.
That's your view.
And a click on that view could
toggle the Wi-Fi on and off
without ever directing
the user into the Settings
app, which is super-useful.
But these are
still only scraping
the surface of what widgets
can do for you and for users.
Think about a calendar widget.
The view can adjust
to fill whatever
size the user gives it, listing
out all the events for today.
Clicking on an event can
open up its detail view,
and scrolling through the
list can show you everything
that doesn't fit in the view.
And just because
you're showing a list
doesn't mean you can't provide
space for a quick Add action
to easily create a new
event in a single click.
Widgets are great,
because they empower
you to make your
app useful to users
even when they haven't
specifically opened it.
And then you can easily get
users back into your app,
because you're enticing them
with completing an action.
So check out the
documentation on widgets
to learn how you can
get started and what
widgets can do for you.
But most importantly, just
continue to build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]